نحن نتواجد الان امام المياه الاقليميه
الجيبوتيه والتي باتت مكانا لانتظار
العديد من السفن بعد ان تقطعت بها السبل
بسبب استمرار المواجهات المسلحه بين
بريطانيا وامريكا من جهه وجماعه الحوثي من
جهه اخرى كما تشاهدون خلفي هناك عدد من
السفن العالقه والتي لم تتمكن من العبور
من مضيق باب المندب بسبب تحضيرات القوه
البحريه المشتركه لكافه السفن من ابتعاد
عن هذا المضيق حتى اشعار اخر بسبب استمرار
المواجهه المسلحه هذه السفن اثرت البقاء
والانتظار خوفا حتى وان حتى ان لم تكن
متجهه لاسرائيل لكن خوفا من ان تصيبها ان
تصيبها قذيفه طائشه او يتم اصابته بالخطا
وبالتالي هي اثرت البقاء في هذه المنطقه
وبعضه ايضا فضل الالتفاف من حيث راس
الرجاء الصالح سيما ان الفتره التي قد
تمكث هنا هي فتره غير معروفه وبالتالي هذا
كان متوقعا بسبب تحول هذه المنطقه الى
بؤره نزاع مسلح هناك الكثير من السفن
تتخوف من العبور من هذه المنطقه وبالتالي
هذه احد السلبيات التي تسببت في النزاع
المسلح على خط الملاحه البحريه حسن رزاق
الجزيره من امام المياه الاقليميه
الجيبوتيه